à montfermeil en seine saint denis l'an
passé déjà le maire pierre bernard avait
refusé d'inscrire des enfants
d'étrangers à l'école primaire seule
l'intervention du préfet avait pu
infléchir cette décision cette année
c'est en classe de maternelle que
monsieur bernard refuse d'accueillir ces
enfants
l'enquète de michel taubmann il reste
encore des places dans trois maternelles
de montfermeil
mais le maire divers droite refusent d'y
inscrire une quarantaine d'enfants à
cause de leurs origines étrangers une
discrimination illégale justifiée par la
sociologie de la ville 23 communautés
différentes 25 % d'immigrés et même 85%
dans certains immeubles de la cité des
bosquets lorsqu'on dit le maire de
montfermeil raciste convenez que j'ai
envie de rire et je dis à tous les
français veulent et donc voir dans nos
écoles alors je pourrais être considérée
comme raciste parce qu'il n'y a plus de
français dans ces écoles
effectivement donc et 85 % d'enfants
étrangers
c'est à mon avis beaucoup et cela risque
d'entacher cela entache d'ailleurs une
scolarité normale
d'abord pour les enfants étrangers et
bien sûr pour les enfants français
problème il est d'abord d'ordre social
ce sont l'ensemble des populations
défavorisées qui sont aujourd'hui
victimes d'un système éducatif et au
lieu de poser le problème en mettent en
faisant prévaloir ce qui ne va pas dans
ce système éducatif c'est à dire le
problème de des enseignants qui ne sont
peut-être pas formés le manque de
d'établissements scolaires
on met à l'index des enfants désavoué
hier par le ministre de l'éducation
nationale le maire de montfermeil face à
l'attack sur un autre terrain celui des
lectures enfantines six ouvrages ont
déjà été retirés de la bibliothèque
municipale à l'initiative d'un comité de
lecture présidée par l'épousé du maire
qui juge ces livres subversifs
dans ce livre on explique très bien
comment un enfant comme tous les enfants
demandent à son grand père s'il pourrait
lui conçu un vélo et son grand père lui
dit je peur d'en construire un il n'y a
pas de problème d' essentiel c'est que
tu me vole les pièces dans les grandes
surfaces
et voilà les adultes qui poussent les
enfants au vol la moralisation de la
bibliothèque inquiète les milieux
scolaires et ce
du livre enfantin qui y voient
l'influencé de l'uni syndicat
universitaire très marqué à droite dont
s'inspire la présidente du comité de
lecture par ailleurs épouse du maire on
au courrier que j'ai eue de madame
bernard elle me donne toute une liste de
livres dieu quelle banque dont elle met
en cause un passage c'est pas possible
de juger d'un livre sur une phrase ont
retiré son contexte moralisation
littéraire discrimination ethnique
deux affaires distinctes mais
révélatrice d'une philosophie
autoritaire et peut-être aussi d'un
certaine électoralisme dans une ville où
le front national représente 17% des
voix
et puis monsieur pierre bernard donc
vient de faire savoir ce soir qu'il
démissionnerait dans l'hypothèse où des
pressions le bij aurait donc à
scolarisés en maternelle les enfants de
moins de cinq ans des familles immigrées